coiffure grâce à un communiqué militer
j'espère peut-être communiqué passer
derrière le mur ce fameux mur de
l'incommunicabilité
m
vous
bonjour une petite saint-just une entrée
semin communicabilité n'arrivons pas
communiqué alors nous essayons de de
traduire cette espèce de deux drames
très loin nous traduisons avec notre à
moi mon art c'est la musique
je m'exprime en musique c'est l'extrême
en peinture
sans faire de l'art avec tout on peut
faire de l'art avec des cailloux avec de
l'herbe avec des branches d'arbres avec
du plastique avec un crayon et un papier
et on peut encore faire de la musique je
vous assure avec un crayon et un papier
et je suis en train de revenir mais tout
premier amour c'est la musique la
musique complètement naturel
la musique de la voix humaine où la
musique d'un instrument tout simple
quand je suis venu à saint paul en mille
il ya de ça deux ans j'ai voulu
présenter mes oeuvres mes oeuvres sous
un jour moderne actuelle donc donc un
jour de révolte puisque mon ma création
est une révolte herbe vêtus elle donc
j'ai présenté mon art plastique si vous
voulez j'ai présenté ma musique sous
forme de tricot de rézé mise en conserve
dans des beaucoup je sais je fais
tricoter maison magnétique s'est fait
tresser alors évidemment tout ça pouvait
passer pour une provocation
finalement pour moi c'est pas une
provocation pour moi c'est une création
en mettant ma musique en conserve j'ai
créé
il m'est arrivé de faire des concerts de
provocation et je le dis et j'espère
refaire des concerts de provocation
parce que dans la provocation il y as
recherche les stimulations il y à
ambition il y as création il y as
invention et tous ah bon vous amène
quelques fois à passer les limites comme
dit jean cocteau
il faut savoir jusqu'où on peut aller
trop loin et de temps en temps on va un
peu trop loin
être compositeur de chansonnette ou être
compositeur de musique contemporaine
pour moi c'est la même chose d'être
compositeur s'être compositeur qui a pas
36 façons d'écrire de la musique du
ciron disons que le sirop que je compose
c'est quand même un sirop que j'aime
bien je cracherais pas dessus
d'abord le public me le rend bien quand
j'écris les mélodies que le repos du
guerrier ou des mélodies comme pour la
marquise des anges par exemple
ce ne sont pas des mélodies que je
refuse que je que je méprise le
contraire je les aime bien
si difficile de série mais la liste est
souvent plus difficile de faire et de
mélodies que de faire une musique
contemporaine
c'est très difficile il ya très peu de
compositeurs qui font de bonnes et
j'aime bien faire des bonnes mélodies
comme dans mélodie en sous-sol avec
henri verneuil un singe en hiver avec
henri verneuil la ronde avec vadim et
jane fonda et puis j'ai fait aussi des
films avec jean yanne évidemment tout le
monde il est beau ce que c'était quand
même très amusant je pense qu'à partir
du moment où on donne toutefois même le
bluff
qu'est ce que c'est que le bluff en fait
ce sont ceux qui ne font rien mais ceux
qui travaillent ce qui donne tout tout
de même ceux qui expriment tout ce
qu'ils pensent et tout ce qu'ils peuvent
faire
impossible de le faire les metteurs en
scène ils ne parlent pas le même langage
que nous nous parlons un jargon
complètement différent c'est
l'incommunicabilité total sauf avec
quelques metteurs en scène copains comme
j'ai eu avec la div
par exemple costa gavras
ils sont des gens avec lesquels j'ai
sympathisé merveilleusement bien
mais souvent on parle un langage
tellement différent que je connais de
metteur en scène
ils nous passent une commande pour une
chose préciser si on a le malheur de
faire la chose précise c'est une
catastrophe
quand c'est avec un instrument
laurbou piano je suis tentée affaires
2010 un tout petit peu plus tarabiscotés
un tout petit peu plus complexe parce
que les harmonies elle-même du piano par
exemple une petite base comme ça que
tout simple il ya forcément des
harmoniques on est tenté de m
ça m'amène à autre chose
et
on
par exemple ça j'aurais jamais fait ça
si j'avais écrit
dans un restaurant sur une table comme
je le fais souvent je prends un papier
un crayon
les mélodies sont moins intérêt
discothèque c'est plus simple à
je pense que quand même la peinture et
la musique sont deux à très différents
j'espère qu'avec ces musiques visuel
touché si vous voulez aux rapports des
deux c'est toutes ces pièces là là je
vous en fais voir que deux mais je vous
en fera voir d'autres elles ont toutes
un enregistrement qui correspond
exactement à l'heure tu es compliqué
parce que pour moi ce sont des tableaux
ce sont des tableaux si vous mettez ce
l'armure c'est un tableau il n'y a pas
de problème j'estime que c'est un
tableau mais j'estime aussi que c'est
une partition c'est une partition la
preuve c'est que on peut jouer ses
oeuvres
donc ce sont des partitions tableau
alors tous les sujets que vous voyez ici
sont des sujets qui ont rapport à
l'incommunicabilité
la musique intellectuelle ne se veut pas
populaire ça me demande pourquoi la
musique intellectuelle malheureusement à
paris et se cloisonne dans des chapelles
et ses chapelles ans de moins en moins
de public
et
c'est par edf et le déficit lui il
s'agit de plérin grand nombre mais moi
mon problème c'est de plaire à un grand
nombre je ne veux pas plaire à 2000
personnes ça ne passe pas
incommunicabilité c'est une chose
maintenant la synthèse peut être une
solution
alors je recherche toujours des fun mais
en ce moment par exemple je fais je fais
des synthèses photographique pour ça je
prends une partition je prends une autre
partition et photographiquement avec des
négatifs ou des positif vous allez
superposent et j'obtiens une troisième
partition qui n'a rien à voir avec ces
deux premières et j'appelle ça une
synthèse parce que cette troisième
partition est bien née des deux
partitions et pourtant elle n'a rien à
voir ni avec lui ni avec m
c'est vraiment une nouvelle
la crise oblige
çà et là
c'est la suite de moshe maoz parce que
monsieur mouse qui a eu beaucoup de mal
à démarrer en france qui n'a même pas de
marée du touquet était habile dit ce
qu'on appelle avoir peur de le dire en
amérique ça marche très bien
c'est très loin des marais ces jeux dans
les cafés-théâtres partie kaplan qui le
chante dans les cafés théâtres et j'en
suis très content parce que je pense que
je pense que monsieur mouse va devenir
quelque chose d'important
la musique de demain je serai bien dire
incapable de vous dire quelle sera la
musique de demain je vous parlais
simplement de la musique d'aujourd'hui
la musique aujourd'hui en occident car
le vison en occident est complètement
barré sur une musique technique ou
techniques tellement avancé que
malheureusement le public n'a pas suivi
il ne suis pas pour une raison bien
simple c'est que bien souvent dans cette
musique le coeur n'y est pas l'avenir et
je ne veux pas dire du mal de la musique
contemporaine qui est une musique que
indispensable à notre époque dit de
création d'invention de recherche que
vous pratiquez que je pratique que je
pratique la bonne escient puisque dieu
sait si je baigne dedans et si jeune que
c'est intégrer mais je trouve que si on
veut aller plus loin si on veut faire
une musique moderne qui ce soir en même
temps une musique universelle car il n'y
a pas de musique si ce n'est pas
universelle il faut se tourner un peu
dans la spiritualité ça j'en suis
certain nous avons oublié depuis des
générations nous avons oublié la
spiritualité ça c'est très très grave
il faut que la musique devienne le plus
en plus une musique du coeur et du vrai
coeur pas du coeur facile de l'âme et
malheureusement ça c'est quelque chose
que nous avons complètement oublié alors
la musique de demain sera peut-être
cette musique là
et bien comme vous le voyez je suis en
train de retour les mater dans semences
et je suis en train de labourer je suis
en train de retourner et c'est très
important pour la culture
gréer comprendre
vous comprenez bien qu'il ne s'agit pas
de planter un concerto comme symphonie
c'est pas la même terre
où
m